it has never been less valuable to be
smart about information than today the
way we educate our children right now is
so broken
it actually has zero value professors
aren't relevant to a lot of their
students today more than ever which is
why it's insane what our children are
going through in the school system
making them memorize facts that are
there fingertips most kids are learning
more on their own than they are in the
classroom because they have more
information at their fingertips
who is the 19th president oh I don't
know this guy so many people have
emailed me like literally because of
this show emailed me that hey I'm in
class right now and what my professors
talking about makes no sense the
Internet is the biggest culture shift in
the history of human beings we are
teaching our children to memorize [ __ ]
and then regurgitate it I hope my
children BDNF students and that gives me
time since they're not gonna work on
homework for me to teach them the real
[ __ ] and literally professors in major
universities that are putting kids in
debt right now are telling them that
there is no ROI in social media like
ludicrous horse crap I'm so disgusted
with what's going on universities across
this country there is a rolling and
checking the doubt going on in
classrooms all across this country and
it's sad because of the romance of how
professors think it should be versus the
reality of what it's like